this one says what 2020 has taught us
that not everyone should make sourdough
hi i'm natasha legero hi i'm rachel
brosnahan and we are here with wired to
answer the most
googled questions about 2020. i'm scared
okay
let's do this
[Music]
should the 2020 world series
count is that basketball yes
then it should count hashtag sports
which 2020 nfl teams
are undefeated you know what's
interesting is
nfl stands for not for legero
the giants that was my high school
mascot
is 2020 a la nina year was that a
hurricane
or a sports team i don't know let's go
with yes
yes definitely our 2020 election
results final yes yes
that guy lost we don't have to have his
voice
echoing through our homes anymore
how 2020 changed the world i'm all for
keeping the personal bubble
post 2020. i personally love
telling people to back the away from me
like whenever they come close
except that you can't cancel digital
plans it's so much harder to cancel
virtual things
you can't cancel cocktail hour because
everyone's like what the [ __ ] are you
doing you're just in your house
and virtual plans are like 50 worse than
real plans
only 50 70 77
where 2020 super bowl natasha
where let me take a guess and i'm just
gonna guess a place that i would like to
go
um montenegro okay
yeah take me to the super bowl baby okay
how 2020 mlb playoffs work i
i don't even know what this is i'm not
even like trying to be funny like
mlb do you have any idea i do actually
know
major league baseball this is baseball
that one i know
they work um in a bubble
[Music]
everyone doesn't get to slap each other
on the ass this year
no ass slapping in this year's playoffs
will 2020 go
down in history interesting people are
googling that
it'll go down somewhere
next question has 2020 had
the most hurricanes yeah
yeah inside and outside of the home
it has felt like hurricane season for
about a year
it's 2020 a leap year um
if you mean leap off of a cliff into
a fire pit of hell then yes i would say
it's a good leap year
yeah is 2020 the year
of the rat i mean it's kind of the year
of rudy giuliani so
yes is that his nickname that's a
perfect nickname for him
are 20 20 pennies worth anything
uh one cent is my understanding
did 2020 vmas have an audience now i
actually know what that is
and i do know that their audience was a
bunch of
beautiful gen z cutouts ah
smart i mean i don't know i'm just
guessing
does 2020 have 53 weeks
i feel like 2020 has 103 weeks
yeah it feels like it's been like 6 000
days
has 2020 been the worst year in history
you know this one's interesting
there have been some pretty gnarly years
it's not a great year in history
i would say 2017 when my comedy central
show another period was canceled was
definitely worse
so no who is 2020 world series
mvp natasha legero
you know i thought claire foy's
performance was very understated
but uh olivia coleman was the winner
did 2020 start a new
decade i feel like this is a trick
question that would be on are you
smarter than a fifth grader
and we would not be i went to public
school so i'm not really sure but it
does
feel that it started a new decade yeah
did 2020 skip easter uh i converted to
judaism just so i don't have to answer
stuff like this
i'm gonna go with yes although i did see
the easter bunny in times square so
maybe not cute who is
20 20 mba
mvp uh aoc
[Music]
where 2020 world series played
um in our living rooms no yes good
answer
thank you how many days in 2020 i
actually know this one
it's 600 050.
did 2020 have the highest voter turnout
yes thank you young people
thank you black women thank you
activists on the ground who got people
out to
vote yes can 2020 be
over already so soon so so
soon this sounds like a 14 year old type
this in
what best meme of 2020 i loved the fly
the internet was at its prime with mike
pence's fly
god sent that fly to mike pence
2020 would you rather would you
rather lick a seat on the subway
or touch an elevator button in times
square oh i would definitely touch an
elevator button
really i don't know i feel like they
clean the subway a lot
which 2020 corvette is the fastest
who's buying a corvette in 2020 my
husband bought like a night rider
corvette from the 80s
um and he had it parked in our garage
for about eight months
and then i made him sell it so not yours
not your corvette do 2020 ap
exams matter i don't think they should
have to matter this year
how do you learn ap stuff on zoom cancel
ap exams 2020. was 2020 the hottest year
on
record fire season was i think the worst
on record so i don't know if that also
translates into the hottest year on
record but i would assume so
because fire equals hot hottest in the
bedroom
rachel um has the pandemic made you
pretty horny
listen natasha that is
uh was 2020 mentioned and back to the
future
good question i'm going to say yes 2020
should i buy a house if you can will
2020 be a cold winter
oh i hope not that's just mean at the
end of this year
move to la it's nice here it's always 75
and then when the um
fires start i actually don't know how to
help you should 2020 be declared a
zero year yes
[Music]
yes it should what 2020 looks like
looks like an old bar hag who's been you
know he's at the bar at like
4 30 and she just fell off of her chair
with a lit cigarette and people are just
like walking on top of her and it's just
a mess
was 2020 a recession not only was there
a recession there was also a little
thing we like to call a pandemic
a global pandemic 2020 was out here
doing
all the things when 2020 taxes due april
15th dog
i say dog now does the 2020 rav4
have a sunrise i live in new york i
wouldn't know
my dad actually bought one of these and
yes that's one of the appeals like it's
like a jeep that has like the the top
off but he lives in florida so
how 2020 started
[Music]
now let's do how it ended yeah how it
ended
[Music]
will 2020 coins be worth more listen
we're becoming digital we're all going
to get chipped there's not going to be
coins soon
no coins are really worth anything but
save them just in case because it could
be like beanie babies
thank you guys so much for watching i
hope this was inspiring
i feel like um once we got through all
the sports questions
um rachel and i were really able to help
you guys out
i feel like we had a lot to offer